hello everyone welcome to simulation
I'm your host Alan Saki on today we're
sitting down with dr. Joon Yoon hello
how are you Alan thank you for having me
this is a blast yes it's always a
pleasure to sit down with June
very wise wisdom he's the president of
palo alto investors
manages that hedge fund it's got about
two billion dollars in health care
investments and amongst so many other
things and you've probably seen him on
our fireside chat earlier in the month
of December 2017 if you haven't yet go
check that out
we're on patreon so if you find these
talks useful in addition to your likes
comment subscribes you can become a
member by becoming a member you get
great benefits such as you get priority
in asking our guest questions you get
early access to our events and early
access to know who the guests are as
well as exclusive content so become a
patron we'd greatly appreciate that
so we have a bunch of different things
to talk about today we'll jump right
into them so June maybe we start talking
about bubbles bubbles
yeah well bubbles yes what we both live
in a bubble and they're always bubbles
going on both based on fear and greed
I'm not necessarily against bubbles
bubbles actually draw a lot of
investment into areas that otherwise
might not get funded you know I think
humans are always reaching for greatness
and their wins is a time when doors open
wide up for a field and you know and
we're gonna probably end up with too
many ideas too much funding for a period
of time there's always some good that
comes out of it yes there'll be some
pain as well so you know I'm not
necessarily against bubbles just because
there are bubbles there's some utility
now definitely I'm also worried about
bubbles in this sense that oftentimes it
can increase inequality in society
the you know there are people that tend
to find it early oftentimes as the
elites and then the people that are
playing catch up are often the ones that
get burned so by the time you go through
a bubble and bust cycle you look at
what's happened like I you know
oftentimes it kind of widened the class
divisions so in that sense bubbles also
need to be watched and moderated and
addressed at the at the beginning you
also said that we live in a bubble so
does every human with their limited
perception systems live in a bubble in
their limited environments for sure we
all live in our own psychological
bubbles own psychological bubbles and
earlier I was saying that more in the
sense of Silicon Valley bill that we
definitely would bubble our oak level
here which is good and bad I think
there's a lot of [ __ ] I should plug this
voyage is my friend Diaz means new
company that she taught me about
yesterday at Adam gazelle ease First
Fridays and she is bringing together
people from around the world taking
people out of their bubbles to increase
potential for world peace and empathy by
basically making value based alignments
and meetups between people so if you
live in the Middle East or in Africa or
Europe and you want to come visit the US
or vice versa you can you match with
someone else based on values and they
can host you for a period of a couple
days or a week or something like that so
it's a good way to pop out of that
bubble but you're right yes Silicon
Valley has won arguably places in the
Midwest have won and you're right that a
lot of elite can sometimes come in and
maybe reap the advantages of what's
happening and sometimes people that come
in later will not necessarily get that
but overall isn't everyone get uplifted
over time yeah all the time things are
getting better and these bubbles are
oscillations along a arc that is
prosperous and things are getting better
overall we do have these little dark
windows and
you know the suffering around those
times maybe know pretty severe there's
no doubt we're probably gonna have a
down-cycle
economically at some point again it's
been a long ball market so yeah to be
mindful of that but I want to say
something about bubbles that doesn't get
talked about enough and that's the one
of the one of the causes of bubbles is
the fact that things are priced by
people who are not acting rationally not
only because we're irrational general or
irrational general but there are a lot
of people that are managing other
people's well-being in resources and
they are actually acting rationally from
a selfish perspective but they're
actually not behaving as good
fiduciaries so let's talk about this so
we are we are wired for following
Hamilton's rule so the way our human
brain is wired we're supposed to live in
tribal structures with high alignment we
have high genetic interests in those
that are around us
so whether it's information or food or
service or commitment we acted along the
lines of our alignment that's following
Hamilton's rule due to technology we've
spread out and we've moved to new places
we're in front of strangers we have
increased mobility these are generally
good things but our brains have a factor
setting that are based on the old tribal
structures so we tend to expect more
from those that around us than what's
being delivered and that because it's
now counterparty risk those people that
we are interacting with it largely are
strangers they're strangers to us yeah
they're not delivering what we expect
out of them what's happening is they're
now counterparties instead of people
that are aligned with us we tend to
underprice that counterparty risk and so
what we feel is alienation or somehow
we're getting abused or exploited by our
leaders by our politicians by our media
the talking head
big food yeah it's all counterparties
and we don't realize that they're kind
of parties because we're wired for to be
around people that we trust and then we
are loyal to mm-hm
so by underpricing that counterparty
risk we feel betrayed and then we feel
alienated you know you could see this in
even neighborhood behavior now the vast
majority of people live among neighbors
with low genetic alignment so you know
it's been said by others that people put
so much into their kids right now it's
stunning yeah how much they put in their
kids at the same time we're also just
stunned how little people put into the
community yeah
to me they're following him what's wrong
they're so genetically unconnected to
those around them that the only people
they know their genetic connected to are
their kids so in a strange sort of way
they're following that Darwinian
calculus we have a phone call from the
community the canaima who calls you
anymore sure please I you should pick up
and see what they're interested in maybe
we have some probably a counterparty
cell telling you it's a telemarketer
call right so that will still make you
feel further alienated from those around
us so this thing we're feeling like oh
my god everybody's so investment or kids
they're over parenting helicoptering
and they do nothing for each other and
the community is highly Darwinian you
just need to recognize that and really
develop kind of a new social
understanding where we are
we need to acknowledge that these are
the changes we need to embrace the
changes and we need to behave more
appropriately this kind of seems to me a
lot like us to becoming distance from
technology in terms of actually
understanding the underlying mechanisms
of how technology works the children
that are now being born today are not as
aware potentially of what actually
occurs inside of a smartphone and it
seems kind of similar with char booth
where we came from evolutionarily we
came through a more tribal setting where
we were maybe more closer and we didn't
think that other people could take
advantage of us as and now like you
listed all these different industries
where people are potentially being a
little bit selfish and not thinking
about us like their fellow humans on the
planet but rather ask somebody that
could potentially give them more money
and may increase their wealth yes so the
first piece of technology we're down
with is our first pieces our evolution
code so that technology is now
maladapted in many ways let alone our
use of smartphones all the things are
saying those are extensions of ourselves
but our endowed tools are not well fit
for the world that is emerged and will
get better we'll figure this out talks
like this are just part of really
growing awareness the fact that were
even in this state of mental adaptation
relative to our biology and the other
framing here is to just understand that
this change from a lime high alignment
to low alignment and our inability to
appropriately process the fact that
we've shifted from the inclusive fitness
model to a reciprocal altruism model of
behavior and transactions is leading to
behaviors that don't make sense to us
they're maladaptive they're not rational
there's exploitation they're suffering
there's alienation just to understand
that it's a single thing rather than
thinking there's so many different
problems we're gonna solve we just have
to solve one thing which is alignment ok
let's dive into alignment there a little
bit yeah so one way to one way to
correct for alignment if we're not
genetically aligned is to have bodies
that represent us together
there are you know think about the
corpus of a corporation so create this
body called a corporation and we have
shareholders and you can actually create
alignment or amongst a group of people
based on shareholding you're not
partners you have stakes you have goal
congruence which is super important yes
and when you create these bodies of goal
congruence that body can go do wonderful
things together yeah and I think this is
one of the untalked about things that's
great about Silicon Valley there's many
reasons I think Silicon Valley you've
been successful and I
we love the words you pick their goal
congruence and that's very fascinating
as it applies to so many things even
your relationship with your partner it's
so important what are your goals how
often do you guys speak about your goals
and that's your partner not only in your
potentially marital life but that is
also your partner in your business life
how often are you talking about goal
congruent Sarah even in a conversation
so biology wired us for goal congruence
and then social diversity happened and
now we're a very low goal congruence and
so the behaviors people exhibit there's
so much violation of trust and it's now
counterparty risk so again I think the
we can create these artificial
structures that correct for the fact
that biologically were not highly
aligned anymore so startups have and
when I went to watch board members and
management teams they are really in
Silicon Valley they are really good at
assigning equity to align behaviors that
the whole thing moves forward together I
feel it to me it seems like the Silicon
Valley's better than any other place in
the world yeah
and I think that's why they're
successful yes yes whereas what I think
that that same thing applies to service
or retail industry as well absolutely
but but it's there's so little time
mostly it's very very high level
executives at these organizations like
Target or whatever are getting
potentially stocks and and whatnot
but for a mom pawn shop it's much more
so there's one owner and then we pay
everyone else hourly there's no
co-ownership usually without the
traditional model yeah maybe history of
business
everybody had complete ownership there
was no manager owner separation the idea
of there being a manager who's separate
from the owner it was a relatively
modern innovation meaning a manager has
no economic stake in the company and
they get paid as a transaction yeah
now the reason any owner would ever hire
a manager because our managers not going
to act completely the best interest as
if an owner but if you you can't just
run your own business all the time and
scale because you're gonna go from one
sort of five story you can't
you have five places so you hired this
thing called a person called a manager
but then that managers gonna behave in a
way that is not fully maximizing the
value for the owner and we could say
they'd be more disconnected from their
role if they weren't given a share of
potentially the exact right so the thing
to do in those cases is to create goal
congruence it could be bonuses it could
be ownership just the align behaviors in
a way that make the whole thing move
forward and be productive and everybody
shares in that it's kind of the model
that's alignment golden lemon grew all
summer with again Silicon Valley does
that really well when you look at these
large corporations the ownership stake
is so small that one of the reasons that
entrepreneurship dies there's many
reasons that dies in these large
corporations but a lot of it's because
the person just doesn't have enough
incentive their contribution isn't going
to be water it's gonna not gonna be
reflected in their personal well-being
because there's so much solution of
value if you own point zero zero one
percent of a company is your are your
actions every day gonna reflect the best
interest of the overall corporation know
it might be a line through bonuses and
there might be other ways to solve for
that but it's very different than being
a significant stakeholder of a small
company so what that also speaks to us
tribalism just doesn't scale you're not
gonna have the same watch pre-opening
behavior from a person in a ten thousand
person company than a person in a
10-person company so not only do you
want to be early but as a company those
early employees are probably doing great
things because of the high to go
alignment they have yeah so the idea
here is to take that model the genetic
one and the corporate one and figure out
a way to create alignment across all
systems yes so there's so many yeah
exactly so for instance I'll just make
up some crazy ones
right now doctor-patient relationships
are theirs in the olden days we probably
had one doctor for a big chunk of our
lives they probably live in a
neighborhood you probably knew their
family they knew your family that's goal
congruence because you live in the same
community
you kind of want
do the right thing across the board but
in the modern world there's just so much
movement so even if you do well for this
patient they might leave you when their
insurance plan leaves you so you start
managing for the short term so there
might be things that would help your
patients long term well-being but a
doctor or even an insurance company may
not be incentivized to protect the
long-term interest of the patient
because the patient's no longer to be
under your charge within a few years and
it's totally different if you're having
dinner with them and their family but
you knew they couldn't leave because
they had low liquidity that they're your
neighborhood yeah yeah so right now if
you think about all insurers insurers
they know that a patient might leave
them it may be their choice it may not
be their choice I don't know who's gonna
make that decision but if you know that
they're not gonna be a client over the
long haul yeah you're gonna be here for
the short term yeah and so and what
happens is by the time you're 65 you're
gonna hand them over to Medicare so
whatever under investment you did in the
long term health care is gonna be
somebody else's problem yeah so the
behavior insurance of insurance
companies is to not invest in your long
term well-being yes so now missed
alignment miss lemon so let's talk about
a solution I don't know but what if you
could actually create incentives for all
the providers of health on the service
side of the insurance side to have steak
holding and the well-being of that
person long term well-being
yeah that's great same with teachers and
students what if a teacher actually was
a long term stakeholder in the outcome
of their students that's amazing yeah so
this is the food companies good company
exactly what if the way they got paid
wasn't on the transaction but was on
stake holding on a long term well-being
so this I'm speaking very generically
about what the only way to really solved
this statement right now is to figure
out the alignment solution so we have
health education and food should
potentially act more like Silicon Valley
business
the positive same with politics I mean
what if you know what what if leaders
political leaders had a long-term stake
in the well-being the country instead of
these election cycle long yeah behaviors
both on the upside and downside they're
they're absorbing the risk and the
return of the investing the long-term
well-being of the country the people
this shareholder is so interesting but
how do we actually
[Music]
another call of the community and
somebody's not gonna ridore how would we
implement something like the Silicon
Valley business model into food or
healthcare or education with all Texans
that's a whole met but in we test number
one is to define a problem correctly
like we just did number two is to ask
for it and yes yeah I'm agnostic to all
the details yeah how the marketplace
figure it out but once you actually
paint the problem correctly and you do
the correct ask then the marketplace do
this their innovation and ingenuity in
the collaboration hopefully we get out
okay so that's the really high level
vision I really like that a lot there's
a lot of brilliant minds that can help
collaborate and figure out creatively
what is the best way to pursue that Wow
what would it be like if all of the food
companies and healthcare companies
education politics all had some sort of
shareholder equity in my well-being Wow
yeah think of it as steak holding steak
correctly use steak holding a better
design a better future for everybody yes
okay so now let's transition to the
alignment we're talking about alignment
and goal congruence now how do you find
that in your personal life your work
life balance your focus all that stuff
mmm so you know I'm I have fiduciary
responsibilities to many people in my
life I've got family I've got friends
I've got clients I got employees I got
people I work with and you know I do
what I can to deliver on the things that
I am responsible for you know some in
some cases people are entrusting their
precious resources to you and the
commitment is to always think about
their well-being you know one of the
things that happens in the real world is
there is too much self-dealing whether
it's a politician or a money manager a
broker a real estate agent self-dealing
shouldn't be tolerated but it is because
there's just too many it's just it's
number one it's the cultural norm in
many industries and the second thing is
you can always move on to another
relationship so there's not enough
attention being paid to self-dealing
self-dealing is the opposite of
fiduciary responsibilities and online
men right so part of this to not get
overextended I mean if you make too many
commitments you might violate your
future obligations unintentionally yes I
prefer to sit on one board at a time I
take my Finnish obligations seriously
and it's hard to be to deliver there's
too many people so look we have a
manageable business about great clients
but we've got a limited number of
clients I said on one nonprofit board
I've got a relatively small family and
I've got a couple friends and I'm no I'm
not no one of these I'm not out there to
meet you people I can barely take care
of people I already know so you know the
classical sense principally because I've
already got people I've got to deliver
to him so focus on that yeah yeah not
that meeting new people isn't amazing I
totally get why people doing and you
always learn by doing that it's a lot of
upside yeah but if it comes at the cost
of delivering on convinced I've already
made yeah you know I've got to just beat
discipline yes how do you retain that
discipline you just do it again you ask
for it you do it this is very very easy
these things are like the activation
energy to get these things going is very
low you just decide you're gonna do it
and you just start doing it sometimes
people talk to me to tell me it's really
difficult to focus in on doing something
that they really want to set their mind
to or their goal on and just being able
to change your state of your focus and
your physiology completely to be aligned
with the long-term goal that you're
setting your mind on in the short-term
objectives you have to get it is really
important that little kick in the butt
that you need to get going on that
rather than taking some short-term
dopamine love your thing I think we're
pointing to is that their instincts
often betray us so being able to quell
those instincts and voices within us
that definitely takes work
yeah whereas the decision to make
changes in your life they can be done
but if there's these underlying forces
that we got to come up with some other
way to overcome our negative it and
sticks especially doing with our
dopamine drip oh yeah
the I love goal congruence that's I love
those words and I think that I must have
even heard that phrase yeah well in
ruins I don't I think I heard something
similar about a year and a half ago when
someone from a major company that
accelerates other companies what was
telling me that one of the main reasons
that founders kind of butt heads is
because they don't talk about goal
congruence and so immediately I was like
oh I need to go talk about goal
congruence I'm like actually write
everything down and then ask my partner
to write everything down and then that
same thing to your relationship at home
and to the relationship with your kids
or to the relationship with your
exercise in your food and all that kind
of stuff so yeah how can you set that
goal congruence let's I love I love that
I love that okay so something that I've
been so infatuated with recently
so bad has been class-based speciation
and so the division of society by
socioeconomic status like a clear
genetic straight division and that may
be related to all have already happened
that may be happening that may happen
when we only get to another planet or to
space or wherever what are your thoughts
about this um you know humans like all
species are social species and that
means that we belong to groups you know
you as a person you're a group of one on
one extreme and as a humanity were a
group of you know six or seven billion
and we simultaneously are part of many
groups some are more fixed somewhat more
fluid you can be in a marriage you could
be group that more passively like you
could all be you know have brown eyes
some groups are elective some groups are
not elected like you know if you born
with the certain genetic disease that's
an involuntary although other ones you
opt into such as being right Chicago
Cubs fan so we're constantly part of
these spheres including age and you
don't control that economic you
partially control that so and at
different times these lines blur and it
all depends on how you come form are the
groups more polarized and can they get
more polarized over time absolutely it
all depends on how one identifies one
themselves they sound like somebody gets
to say you're this and your dad in
social economics because who nobody's
the arbiter where the cutouts are but
they're definitely known as a time when
class conflict increases that times when
it decreases depends on mobility depends
on language cultural context in a lot of
them great struggles of loss thousand
years have related to class conflict
and what to do by now I don't think
there's a right answer to all of these
things and yet people behave as if their
have the right answer and that's when
things start getting a little wild and
dangerous right when people fill up
these fixed views and all the cognitive
biases starts working against the best
interest but you know I've talked about
in your show before this is what
evolution wants evolutional wants us to
continue to look at things in parallax
so that we don't get into consensus that
you could promotes cognitive and social
evolution to constantly form competing
views and test them out against each
other yeah yeah and and sometimes you
know harder lines between them allow for
more crisp delineation of the ideas but
as it relates to the the concrete like
is one group more right about how to
handle the class confort than others you
know time is it's had just shown us
there's no right answer you know and but
there's reasons to continue to discuss
and try to make it better for as many
people as possible we are getting yes
possible yes yes it never feels good for
people to be struggling to be left
behind but the solutions people have
different ideas yeah do you think that
it's kind of a birth lottery like a roll
of the dice to are born in the US or if
you're born it well there's also there's
always luck involved there yeah maybe
that's not the only one
I mean you yes some people make their
luck I don't think there's a pat answer
but just even because of that whole
birth lottery even from just that one
point that stimulates me enough to want
to care for other people because I could
have easily been in the shoes of
somebody that doesn't have access to
running water and
city and food and so that in itself
makes me want to help because I could
have been in those shoes and I would
have greatly appreciated somebody else
to help me to help me maximize my
potential as well so you said there are
different ways to potentially address
where we're going with the development
and the trajectory of the world how can
we better be inclusive and uplift other
people and focus on that I actually have
an thought for you around that and we'll
see where you take it from here but the
peretta distribution applies to so many
things and with something like the
amount of money on the planet I just I
and I just think about if that money is
being allocated to another boat or
another plane or another materialistic
possession like a Rolex or something and
it's the fifth one or the tenth one for
this person that investment versus
investing that money into hiring 50
people to solve a problem that the world
needs is there a way to have a global
conversation around that to be like
maybe we should reconsider the path of
that money into something that we're
gonna I think this is an example people
have different points of views on this
some probably believe that individuals
in control will be rational actors or
the probably of the individuals are
irrational actors so there should be
governance around how these things are
redistributed the only thing I can say
for sure is that they're both partially
correct but they're definitely not
individually completely correct yeah
neither system is a viable long-term
solution I should say not that it's not
viable no matter what you choose
there'll be people that disagree with
that because I'll observe different set
of issues if you go with one kind of
system so
just being very wise and sentient and
observant and kind about what's going on
the world is I know what its gonna take
yeah and being flexible and so maybe
just this for this last sort of point
how about talking about the overall
awareness of civilization and at times
it seems like we've been gifted this
awareness from Stardust from the cosmos
and we have evolved the revolution
through primates to be where we are and
now we have built all this incredible
vehicles and transport and medicine and
technology and it's amazing but at the
same time what what are we doing to
increase our awareness of our past
history where we came from who we are
today
this functioning vehicle of brain and
heart and then where we're going in the
future
that sort of three point conversation
has hasn't really been addressed to
people to help them increase their
awareness and its fullest so it seems as
though when you look at traffic or when
you look at the way that we ran high
fructose corn syrup throughout society
without even testing it for a long
period of time in a small group it seems
like we're just little teenagers playing
with fireworks instead of you know
adults that are logically and
emotionally trying to organize our world
to be cohesive what do you think
you know I mean there are many people
argue we actually need to be more like
kids that were to adults so I know it's
hard to put a value judgment around that
it's you know and you know this is the
oldest we've ever been sold us you've
ever been yeah and all this we've been
as a society as a country so some all
relative to your content there's no
absolute frame of reference
we're young relative to the future were
old well to the past in some domains we
know much less than we used to ten
thousand years ago such as how to detect
the change of seasons through our
surrounding environment easy in many
ways we know so much more about
ourselves in a world yeah so it's hard
to have like a singular answer for the
people that believe that we are not
aware enough I could totally defend that
point of view to people that I believed
that we're in the golden age I could
totally support that point of view so
it's hard to talk in generalities is be
more where even a good thing I mean I
you know when I ask people the really
deep questions about what are things
that you wish you didn't know people
break down in tears they wish they knew
lesson they did and there's a bliss that
comes with less awareness so you know
these questions are so multi-dimensional
and front with misunderstanding and
framing it's just it's hard to answer
now all that said in general for to have
the option ality to be more aware of
ourselves that the option to elect in
that environment cuz people get so
choose to ignore and be blissfully
ignorant I totally respect that as well
but do you I'm sorry yeah totally you do
oh yeah you can see the you think that's
good for your children and for their
children it's it's for everybody should
decide on their own I mean I don't think
I don't think anybody should prescribe
that that particular morality as to how
much should they know yeah but what if
that person doesn't know the boundaries
of murder yeah that's not good
yeah right and that we'll learn that
lesson because it once you're your
individual freedoms have their limit
as long as you're operating within the
sphere of your own freedom you can do
what you want but when you belong to a
collective society when your freedom
starts impinging on the freedoms of
others
that's a bumper car effect then your
freedoms now need to be constrained then
you have competitive freedom yeah and so
that's that's one you need to be more
you know inclusive of the experience of
others in one's own behavior but if
you're not hurting anybody right then
yeah it should be okay well should be if
you want to live a gluttonous life your
whole life okay that's fine
but if you want to be aware of other
people around you in the trajectory of
the world then maybe you should care a
little bit more about yourself and your
health and also the well-being of others
around you I'm it is definitely very
nuanced and well you got to be able to
hold both of those points of view that
you should respect people's individual
freedom so for people that are let's
just call on the left end of spectrum
need to understand why people are asking
for their freedom but on the right they
need to understand why people want
people to restrain their freedoms in the
global context exactly if the behaviors
start impinging on the well-being of
others yeah so they're both partially
correct and unfortunately many people
behave like they're a hoarder percent
correct do you ever think that we'll get
to a nuanced position where there is of
course it's important to keep that
parallax always this sort of seeing it
from two different ways or from 7
billion different ways to help us grow
but is there some sort of a consensus
that we can strike that's at least
generally good enough no like you don't
murder because it's not human instinct
well we're very we're interest of your
wire but we're also heavily wired by
culture so those again that's parallax
there's a genetic code but it's the
cultural code and we are some blend of
those two things no I think if this very
easy and innate we'd get there so the
idea of just truly understanding the
well-being of individuals versus the
world when your groups it for easy we're
done already so I think we're gonna have
to constantly relearn every generation
the fact that there's competing interest
across evolutionary stratum or biologics
drive there is individual interest as
group interest the strata compete you
know the mob is competing with interests
of individuals and vice versa
yes not only is there a multi-level
selection but there's multi-level
competition that's going on at all times
and within all of that multi-level
competition is there a maybe single
piece of advice that you have for
individuals or families or communities
in order to maybe maximize their own
well-being and others well-being what
would be a cool actionable item maybe to
give people well so call congruence I
think is a whenever we're acting on the
interests of those beyond just ourselves
really aligning interest and being
productive because you know then you can
create win-win
that's how you move things forward
rather than trying to take from each
other that's just a counterparty model
and that's know that doesn't that
doesn't move the world forward as much
often creates worn conflict and
dissension and alienation that's not the
way to do it I think we should be more
forward-looking and be more together so
call congruence I think is the easiest
single phrase and remember and I think
there are a lot of smaller ones just
from a lifestyle perspective to be aware
of I think we have to these are just
practical things we have to be more
concentrated efforts more deliberate
because if we do too many things even
though we intend well we might not
behave in a way that is according to our
commitments so make fewer commitments
and deliver on our commitments
that's is such a building trust and it's
showing respect and then not
everything's gonna go as planned and
intended and looking upon those
situations more kindly something that we
can almost drive its drive for I mean
none of us are perfect again our
intrinsic pre-wired emotions will kick
in but the
get past them right now the internet
that's just it's pretty raw yeah that
degree of conflict and again I'm happy
that there's multiple points of views on
things but to do it in a way that
creates mutual annihilation socially
speaking I'm talking about and that's
that's too much we can we can do better
than that I think that's an excellent
takeaway goal congruence and writing it
out writing it out speaking it out
actually making that a part of your
being in your life with your partner and
your business with your partner at home
with your kids with your health plan
you're exercising all these goals that
you're setting so I will have nay ruins
yes and this is a obviously this is part
of what we're supporting for the 21st
century I think it's just getting proper
orientation linguistically and
culturally twentieth-century I think
what God about as far as we could in
twentieth century so we came out of
savagery it some time to Compton to
contemplate get to know ourselves which
is what we did we started off with Freud
by mid century we had Maslow's hierarchy
so it's really about self-discovery
you've got to look at her belly button
for the century I think in the 21st
century I think will include others in
our understanding good we will include
the second person it just won't be ego
and it and me and actualization and I
think we will start to realize there's
others yeah I think we'll have a much
more a third person and second person
experience in our consciousness so we
need to build out all the psychologic
tools and linguistic tools yeah to have
more collective understanding and to be
more inclusive linguistically and
psychologically and experientially of
others now in order to achieve that like
a simple example there's a lot of talk
about rights and rights are important
but rights come with responsibilities
yes and it'd be nice if responsibility
rose to the same level of mimetic spread
as
right exactly so it's imagine a world
where people are talking about okay I
owe you this knot you owe me this only
right so every human have the obligation
to enrich the world yeah exactly so if
that's a total market rights and
responsibilities net it out then we have
a great world in fact if you have a
positive excess of responsibly relative
the rights
you're probably gonna move the world
fortunately if you have an excess of
rice well that responsibilities you're
gonna create suffering or you're gonna
get mad yourself yeah you're probably
cause offense provoke resentment and
other people know your rights but you
look at your behavior right get your
responsibility are you doing the right
thing yourself a lot of meaning doesn't
come from taking in rights but it comes
on from taking on a responsibility
exactly right so that's the I statement
that Jeremy talks about that we really
need to convert our problem statements
into I statements and then our credits
Amos in the you statements or they
standards imagine describing the world's
problems as first personal statements in
describing the world's greatness and
second at their person that would make
you consulate for credit and others yeah
it also allows one to think about our
own action eyes to the less the first
person yes just an example just what's
possible in the 21st century I have
great hopes yeah exactly
you're right about these neologisms as
new words of vocabulary about how to be
aware of other people and caring for
others and that was good so awesome this
is a good conversation Jun thank you
very much well thanks for having me
was there other stuff you wanted to talk
about I remember I think that's pretty
pretty much good although I think we
pretty much officiated class-b we did
because we did touch on that I think out
of the notes we yeah we did touch on
everything so okay great yeah so thanks
again thank you guys for tuning in we
really appreciate it
big shout out to Ron Vargas Sandra
Thompson our thank you Ron excellent
excellent direction
excellent production work another big
shout out to you guys if you guys had a
good time
you found this content to be useful in
some way please give a like subscribe to
us comment share it with other people we
are on patreon so you can become a
member and if you become a member of
simulation then you get access to our
guests you get access to asking priority
and asking them questions you get access
to all of our exclusive content you get
access to our live events and our guest
list ahead of time so there's all this
great membership stuff so please do join
the family share it around you can find
June dr. June youn or dr Junoon on
twitter you can find a simulation
simulation show and that's it thanks
everyone appreciate it thanks guys
thanks Allen make sure